قاد الأمير تشارلز التحية على
والدته ، وما وصفه بأنه حكمها
الرائع الذي دام 70 عامًا ، قال أيضًا إنه
تم تكريمه لاستخدام إليزابيث
لرسالة اليوبيل الخاصة بها ليقول إنها
تريد أن تُعرف زوجة كاميلا تشارلز
بملكة القرين عندما يصبح تشارلز
ملكًا.  كمكافأة لسنوات من
الخدمة العامة من كاميلا ولكن أيضًا
تأييدًا لنوع الملكية التي
يحاول تشارلز إنشائها ولكن كاميلا
لا تزال شخصية مثيرة للانقسام ، لا يزال بعض الناس
يلومونها على طلاق ديانا
وتشارلز ، وهذا ما يفعله القليل من البريطانيين  كان يجب
أن أقول عن الأخبار ، لا أعتقد أن بعض
الناس سيكونون سعداء جدًا بهذا
القرار
كثيرًا ، لذا فقد حان الوقت ، لكن الكثير
من الأشخاص الذين نشأوا مع
ديانا هي الملكة التالية
التي شعروا بها فعليًا  لقد ظلمت من قبل
المؤسسة الملكية
واه إساءتها وبعد ذلك تعرف
ما حدث بعد الطلاق
وكل ذلك
لذلك لا أعتقد أن الكثير من الناس سيكونون
سعداء جدًا لأن كاميلا حصلت على هذا
هذا الدور رائع وكل شيء ،
لكني أعتقد أن العائلة المالكة هي
مؤسسة ، فقد
يضيع الاحترام الذي يكنه الشعب البريطاني
لها لمجرد
وجود الكثير من الفضائح المحيطة
بحياة تشارلز وكاميلا التي تعرفها
مع وفاة الأميرة ديانا وما إلى ذلك.
لم نر الملكة في ما يسمى
بيوم الانضمام لأنه لا
يمثل بداية
عهد الملكة فحسب ، بل يمثل أيضًا نهاية
عهد والدها ووفاة والدها ،
لذا فهي تنفقها دائمًا بشكل خاص
في عزبة سانجيغام في
الريف  سيأتي وقت الاحتفال
لاحقًا وبلغ ذروته في
عطلة نهاية أسبوع لمدة أربعة أيام تتمحور هنا
في قصر باكنغهام ماكس فوستر سي إن إن
لندن